okay this is it any questions
everybody knows what they're doing right
guess we got one shot at this
[Music]
there's no dumb questions
you guys
did you have a question
no
does all of you guys know exactly what
your job
is okay
so on my count
three
two
one
unbelievable
[Music]
[Music]
was i speeding officer
you don't look like you're from around
here no sir
you've been doing any drugs tonight no
sir
nope
don't you pop that trunk step out of the
vehicle for me
please really
[Music]
no drugs huh
nope
well well well
what have we here
no no no no no you planted that in my
car oh
did
i or did i plant this uh i
i guess it's the car right now oh spread
them uh
huh let's go whoa whoa what do we have
here huh what these are colors homie
that's that's something oh no i don't
know what that or are these your colors
or perhaps these are your colors
or are these look at all these colors
man you sure got a lot of colors
look at all of these colors
are you a real cop freeze what is that
um
well well well
it looks like an illegal firearm
or
is it
oh
i'm i don't i don't know what this is
i'm sorry pick a card
it's not even a good fan any card you
can just stick there okay you took that
card yeah now can you remember that card
yes can you commit that card to memory
this is unbelievable have you done so
have you yes
please insert the card back into the
deck randomly done it's in a different
place than where you took it originally
there we are there we are now
i take the deck like so i give it a
sloisals and abercross royce
is this
your call no are you sure i want your
badge number
how did you do that
and
that is for you
after all that you're still giving me a
ticket is it a ticket
or
is it a two-for-one coupon for my show
at the magic house thursday night at 11
p.m
call
i'll take the ticket
freeze police
hands up
turn around slowly
okay buddy
do not
move a muscle
up up get your hands back up no raise
them up hands up now
no no stop i said no moving put your
foot down
[Music]
that's good
now easy does it no don't pick your
other foot up
put that down put your foot down
put your foot down there we go no do not
pick the other one up put that one down
put your foot down don't not put them
both down okay now you're just walking
stop walking
now
no walking i want you to stop walking
right now do not get near that car wait
get away from it no don't go near that
car don't open that door do not open
that door don't open it do not open the
car door don't you open that door
don't
do not get in that car freeze
your butt better not hit that seat
okay stay get out of there
get out of the car right now no you
don't don't you dare
reach for that glove compartment don't
reach for that glove compartment get
ready to go grab it
get your hand away from the glove
department don't you open it
do not grab that guy
whatever you do dude you better not grab
that gun
you better not grab that car
[Music]
do not pull that gun on me
put that down don't you pull that gun on
me okay
don't do it
damn it god damn it
[Music]
damn it
not again
this is all about susie diaz it's susie
diaz's party susie diaz is running the
show i'm just gonna show up if she's
need to bring beer or something i'm more
than happy to do
oh dude oh my god a woman just fainted
i'm gonna have to call you back
ma'am
man
oh
9-1-1 what is your emergency yes yeah
i'm on the corner of a fifth and
metropolitan and i just came up across
this woman and she just she just passed
out
on the sidewalk here okay and is she
responsive sir
um
okay sir is she responsive
sir
sir
um no sir if you can hear me she's not
responsible she's
beautiful
[Music]
that is not relevant to this emergency
sir an ambulance is on its way in the
meantime i need you to check her pulses
up to check her pulse right check her
pulse okay
does she have a pulser
no she does but your skin is so soft
she doesn't have a ton of makeup but
she's the kind of girl that just doesn't
need it
you can see that she put a lot of
thought into her outfit but that was
just trying too hard
she's perfect
sir may i remind you that you have not
spoken a word to this woman
i need you to see if she's breathing
yeah okay
sir i need you to stay on track
okay she's not breathing but look at my
life is not breathing you gotta save my
baby do you know how to give
mouth-to-mouth resuscitation yes i do
okay i need you to administer that now
okay okay
no no i can't i can't
i can't do it i can't i can't do it it's
just it's disrespectful i have to be
respectful for her sir this is the only
time it's okay to put your mouth on an
unconscious woman do it i just didn't
picture it happening this way there's
butterflies in my stomach and i'm just i
i don't want to mess this up it's so
rare to buy sorry if you can hear me an
ambulance is on its way i'm sorry i'm
sorry i i uh oh gosh my head sorry
sir stay with me this is what it feels
like to be in love with me what it must
feel like when you when you find the
walls
so
9-1-1 what is your emergency there's an
attractive confident
well-to-do black man he just passed out
right here on the street
okay ma'am listen very carefully i'm
going to need you to marry him
oh okay
shouldn't i give him like mouth-to-mouth
first
yeah girl get you some shoes
is 288 i'm investigating the report of a
disturbance
[Music]
[Music]
because i got a popsicle
[Music]
oh rats whoa
watch out that black guy's got a gun and
he's gonna steal your banana
what
[Music]
go go go go go go go go go go go go go
go go go go go go go come on
you're gonna have to leave the area
there's been a disturbance
go for your safety sir go now please
okay go go go get going
big fuzzy guys
i mean it's like it was like you know a
holiday for people having god god damn
it man is on a wall pack who's
responsible for this mess i'm sorry
chief it was me
god damn it
coffee cup my bad
anyway the last seven came out of
nowhere
well believe me you got
vanilla flavored you got
lemon zinger
lemon zinger like that tea oh
what wrong oh no what's going on
i got that brain freeze oh man you do
yeah
[Music]
come on man you said you put the hood
dog you can weak right now with this
brain freeze
come on ain't no brain freeze gonna make
you yell like that man get over it don't
be hitting your head with the brain
freaks come on in it yo you want silver
balls on it silver balls on the string
kinetic
wrong with energy come on okay exorcist
what are you doing now what are you
doing some kung fu get over it man
listen
it can't be doing this much to you
listen man don't be a punk ass [ __ ] man
get over where you afraid now you see
anything you're just scared the brain
free's making you scared
who are you
believe me who am i you ain't got no
alzheimer's what's wrong with you
you're a punk ass [ __ ] what is this
three stooges on this mop
this is some craziness oh you did the
hand block
you know what man you're weak man you're
a weak ass mother that's the problem
yo hold up now hold up now hold up now
hold up now hold up man you're gonna
continue to eat the froyo even on top of
the breakfast
what are you doing
hey now i really start to respect you
now man if you're gonna eat the thing
that's causing you the pain this is
great oh now he's going faster he's
spinning
he's staring into the brain free
this is straight crazy right here
we'll talk about we'll talk about real
talk though i mean it's crazy at the
time man that i strangled benny with my
bare hands cause he didn't have my money
all right we got him kahu
[Music]
what what's your favorite stand up
slowly
i can't believe it's not knowing you
since sixth grade you under arrest for
the murder of bennytac theratrix get him
out of here man you a punk ass brain
freeze mother
you going to jail for a long time
i'll be too deep
ah
i got the brain freeze
i got caught with the brain freeze yeah
you got that brain freeze get him out of
here
[Music]